ننتقل لمتابعه هذه المراسم في بغداد
لاستقبال الامير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن
حمد التاني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا نتابع مراسم استقبال امير دوله قطر
الشيخ امين بن حمد الثاني الذي تم
استقباله في مطار بغداد عن طريق محمد شيع
السوداني رئيس الوزراء هذه الزياره تعد
الاول زياره لقائد عربي بعد تولي محمد
السوداني رئاسه الوزراء في العراق يتوقع
ان يتم توقيع عدد من الاتفاقيات التعاون
بين البلدين نتابع اكثر هذه الملفات
الرئيسيه التي سيتم تناولها مع مراسلينا
من القصر الحكومي في بغداد مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد ابراهيم كما ينضم الينا من
هناك ايضا مراسل جزيره احمد الجاسم
ابدا معك وليد طبعا نتابع في هذه اللحظات
مراسم استقبال امير دوله قطر في بغداد
ونترك لك
تفاصيل اكثر حول هذه المراسم بالاضافه الى
برنامج السير
الزهار بالاضافه الى ما قلتموه قبل قليل
انها اول زياره لزعيم عربي الى بغداد منذ
تولي رئيس الوزراء الحالي محمد شياع
السوداني مقاليد السلطه في اكتوبر من
العام الماضي يقول رغم ان هذه اول زياره
لزعيم عربي لكن ايضا لاول مره نرى هذه
الحفاوه العاليه في الاستقبال لم تجري
العاده من قبل ان يقوم رئيس الوزراء
باستقبال الضيف في المطار ثم يصار فيما
بعد ذلك الى اجراء مراسيم استقبال هنا في
القصر الحكومي في العاده يكون استقبال
الضيف من قبل احد الوزراء ثم يتم الانتقال
الى القصر الحكومي لاجراء المراسيم
الاستقبال الرسميه لكن ان يستقبل رئيس
الوزراء العراقي ضيفه امير قطع في مطار
بغداد وينتقل
الزعيمان الى القصر الحكومي لتجري هذه
المراسيم الرسميه هذه تعكس هذه الحفاوه
الكبيره التي تقوم بها الحكومه العراقيه
في استقبال ضيفها امير قطر على ايه حال
كنت قبل قليل استمع الى وزير النقل
العراقي الذي كان يتواجد قربنا هنا وتحدث
عن اهميه هذه الزياره وقال انها زياره
مهمه جدا على السعيد ليس فقط الاقتصادي
لكن ايضا على صعيد السياسي والاستثماري
فالعراق ينظر بعين كبيره ويتطلع الى ان
تساهم هذه الزياره في احداث نقله حقيقيه
في العلاقات بين البلدين وايضا نقله في
المذكره او من خلال المذكرات التي سيتم
التوقيع عليها نقله في تعزيز التعاون
الاقتصادي والتجاري في البلدين تحدث وزير
النقل العراقي قبل قليل وقال انما بين ما
سيتم التوقيع عليه هو اتفاقيه في النقل
التفاصيل اكثر حول مات سيتم توقيعه من
اتفاقيات ونحن نتابع ايضا هذه الصور
للاستقبال الرسمي لامير دوله قطر الشيخ
امين بن حمد الثاني في القصر الحكومي